We're glad you're back.
In the last lesson you practiced
building better inputs.
You practiced picking
the right input types.
You enabled autofill.
You added clickable labels and
you validated inputs.
>> Now it's time to take a step back
from perfecting individual input and
start thinking about designing
better forms made of many inputs.
This lesson is particularly
important for e-commerce,
where better forms means more sales.
>> Yeah, this is really,
really important.
And take a look at PayPal's
ridiculous rise in mobile payments.
I think it makes sense that this
lesson also focuses on creating great
mobile experiences.
>> Definitely.
Luckily, there are a few basic
principles everyone can follow
to build better forms on every platform.
And they also apply well
outside of e-commerce.
Your ultimate goal is to minimize
the amount of time your user spends
filling out forms.
>> In this lesson, you'll practice
techniques to make forms mentally
easier for your users to handle.
And at the end of the lesson,
you'll be given two ugly,
nasty forms with low conversion rates.
It'll be your job to apply best
practices to improve the forms and
boost conversion rates.
>> Awesome.
Let's go.
>> Yeah, let's go.